laughing laughing it
flighty so high-level things up up
what then
well assalamualaikum - later care to
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are doing well hope the
mercy and blessings of God Almighty is
upon you all before I start when praise
god all-mighty the most merciful the
most just or praises and glory belong to
him now
recently the reason why I'm doing this
video is obviously targeted this message
I wanted to reach sister Lindsay Lohan
and Jack Jones preferably I need you
guys help with that to share this video
with them on the Twitter snapchat
Facebook Instagram wherever it may be
please please share this share this
video with them because missing I've
seen two incidents from both of them
we're basically Jack Jones made a
posting that he read the Quran and he's
not a person that likes to read but I
found a book really powerful and that
was moving you know a lot of people
liked it and supported them but also he
got a lot of hate with it and a lot of
people were swearing I continued doing
it for this reason and that reason and
basically hate full of hate sister
Lindsay Lohan is in Turkey but recently
she was and she was doing some charity
work and she did an interview which I
want you guys to watch hopefully so I'm
gonna you guys to watch that I'm gonna
return straight back in America I was
going through a lot with positive things
that had happened to me over ten years
span and my very close friends who had
been there for me a lot in London or
Saudi and they gave me Quran and I
brought it to New York because I was
learning and I was and it was it opened
doors for me to experience and
spiritually to find another you know
true meaning and this is who I am
this is just me holding it with me
walking going whereas the paparazzi
maybe across the street I didn't know
and they crucified me for it in America
they made me seem like Satan I was a bad
person for holding that Quran and that
and I was so happy to leave and go back
to London after that because I felt so
unsafe in my own country after this I
mean people weren't like horrible to me
and just because this is my belief if I
were if this is something I want to I
want to learn this is a live person all
my or well this is not for you to
express if you want to say it keep it to
yourself I'm not looking at what you do
every day maybe you're not doing enough
because you're bored hurting me
but I can't imagine how many people go
through this all the time and that made
me feel like an outsider so I understand
why
you know the Turkish people are upset
because they live in a great beautiful
place and I understand why women that
were headscarves are looked at
differently because I felt like that so
when the woman when I was in on tap she
put that headscarf on me
I felt really honored because of that
because she went out of her own way to
allow me to be part of her culture and
she didn't have to do that you know I
was a stranger to her and I merely said
I really liked the color of her
headscarf and she gave it to me and
maybe she only has two and she gave me
one there's more to that story that
occurs unless did you know what because
this woman took the time to give me this
and a part of herself not even knowing
me I'm not taking it off and and my
first thought and I and I said to my
good friend hello I said but it scares
because people are going to look at the
headscarf and really talk about that
they're not going to ask the real
questions about why because that's not
interesting it will become helpline
suddenly right you know and it should it
should it should be headlines it's okay
because in Turkey you have a free will
as a woman if you want to or you don't
want to that's why it's amazing here you
can choose what you want and it's
accepted whereas I'm in America holding
a Quran and I'm the devil no you have to
you have to acknowledge the good parts
of a place where we think is so bad you
know people think it's so dangerous it's
really like we're sitting in a really
nice place and we're very lucky to even
be here so it's about time we start you
know recognizing the truth and doing
something so I think I saw for yourself
on the interview she's like she's
emotional about it the fact that she's
seen that she read the Quran that she
got attack left right center and he saw
said though it's the attack that she got
is from the same society that believe in
freedom of choice and freedom of doing
what you want to do and how you want to
do it they believe that and cherish this
then if that's the case why is it that
when an individual decides to read the
Quran or to accept this stuff why is
there so much hate on them why is there
so much hate on Islam why now the reason
why I wanted to do this video is because
I taught you to relate with Jack Jones
and I totally relate with since sister
Lindsay Lohan because before I came to
Islam I always believed in a crater my
family hated this up you know my dad
specifically he hated his time at
handling he's changed now he's a bit
better so hamdullah
he hated Islam and I know exactly where
they come from because it's the like
when I first got my first Quran like
remember got it from nothing like I can
remember I was working with my dad I got
a nice to hide it when I was to read it
every time I dad will come enough to
hide it read it every now and then it
took me like about like a year and a
half you know cuz I was looking into the
religion or a 3-4 years but it took me
such a long time the fact that you can't
comfortably read the scripture so I
totally relate with you guys now this is
the reason why I wanted to do this video
because even though my community was
against it they hated Islam one thing
that I need to ask myself is this Ali if
you believe there's a crater and if you
believe the scriptures from God that
there are signs that sure this is from
God
are you going to reject this alternate
blind eye to it because of the hate
you're gonna get or are you going to
realize that this is from God Almighty
and there's every signs that you believe
yourself that this is from God are you
going to follow this to the best of your
ability now I made a decision say you
know what I'm gonna get hate there's
that times where I've been kicked out of
my house you know I've stayed at Moses
house upstairs right so that's another
story can watch it my Reaver story a
video that I've done on my channel now I
took all this on board because I
realized I said you know what this is
the truth I'm not going to turn a blind
eye to truth and say you know what it
might affect me financially it might
affect me not living being kicked out of
my house
or get hay or get beaten up once you
acknowledge and say this is the truth
that is a decision that you need to be
true to yourself and say you know this
is the religion of chose and this the
religion I'm going to follow and that's
the reason why I wanted to do this video
to support like show my support to you
guys and I understand that we live in a
society where Islamophobia is on the
rise and it's time is being attacked
left right center and there's millions
of money a pound being pumped into
Islamophobia
this is alter to the truth and
misrepresent Islam so I don't long this
video even further Jack Jones you live
in the UK if you do ever want to see
myself or any other brothers and get to
know more about it's done we are happy
to do that we can take you out for lunch
obviously hello I'm joking you know that
you can you can still have your pork
ribs so sis a Lindsay Lohan obviously if
you're watching this we can't come there
even though we can maybe but we can get
in contact with sisters if there's
anything I
can do personally I'll be happy with my
team please watch this and hope you
benefit and please read the Quran and
ask you guys to do one thing if you
believe in the Creator just pray to God
because Allah says in the Quran I
respond to the caller that calls upon me
and all it doesn't say only a Muslim you
know anyone that's truly seeking Him he
will respond so I ask you guys and this
goes to all the people out there who are
looking to read the Quran and look into
Islam read the Quran for yourself do a
pray and ask God for guidance and he
will guide you so I'm not going to carry
any further hope you guys have
benefitted i'm not consider if there's
any reverse out there or anyone who's
interested in it's done I live in London
I'm happy to meet you guys
and speak to you guys in put in a public
place wherever it may be
so please please guys share this with
sister Lindsay Lohan and brother Jack
Jones and thank you for watching hope
you guys are benefited assalam alayka
relate better care to for me and my
brother Musa please can you come here
please please his royal face has always
been thumbs up
nah man
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo